shut your eyes cover your ears and pinch
your nose cuz Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker is going to turn your brain to
goo and send it leaking out of your head
more specifically the final shot of the
upcoming Star Wars flick will quote melt
your mind
according to die-hard Star Wars fan and
filmmaker Kevin Smith speaking with IGN
during 2019 San Diego comic-con Smith
recalled his experience on the set of
the rise of Skywalker where director JJ
Abrams and the film's crew were sending
him mixed signals about a certain set
piece that is the set piece used for the
closing shot of the film and thus the
final frame of the entire Skywalker saga
Smith detailed that some folks at
Pinewood Studios where the rise of
Skywalker was being filmed advised him
to not look at the final shot set piece
as it's shocking enough to anyone who
sees it on the other hand some people
urged Smith to take a peek at it for
that same reason and there was a
scuttlebutt about set thereon at
Pinewood you have to see this when you
see it it'll melt your mind when Smith
asked why abrams told him it was the
last shot of the movie you don't want
this spoiled you want to be in a theater
when this happens trust me and then
other people on the crew were like bro I
wish I hadn't seen it I'm glad I did
he's gone but it will melt your mind
Smith continued noting that it was
almost impossible for him to resist the
temptation to look at the final shot of
the rise of Skywalker ultimately though
his willpower was strong enough and
Smith walked away from his time on the
film set with confidence that whatever
the rise of Skywalker ends on it will be
incredible thanks to JJ Abrams he also
underscored the importance of trusting
filmmakers and not cheating oneself out
of an amazing cinematic experience by
looking at spoilers JJ is such a magical
magician that I'm just like you know
what do it trick me I'll wait and get
tricked even though I could have seen
what it was I was like I'll sit back I
like your plan what this final shot
could be we truly have not a single clue
but whatever it is someone told Smith
that it's pretty impressive and that's
well that's something right it's
definitely not nothing okay maybe it's
only slightly better than nothing
because let's remember when it comes to
all things Star Wars Kevin Smith is not
what you might call an objective source
remember his first movie clerks
which featured an extended discussion on
the ethics of blowing up the second
Death Star in Return of the Jedi which
was likely filled with contractors
working hard to finish construction
think the average stormtrooper does that
install a toilet main they know his
killing in white uniforms think back to
his second feature film Mallrats
a movie in which his character Silent
Bob spent considerable screen time
attempting to master the Jedi mind-trick
dude or encourage him and then chasing
amy his third movie actually features a
long rant about the racial politics of
the original Star Wars trilogy in the
film's first batch of scenes so while
someone almost certainly told Smith that
watching that last scene would melt his
mind it's important to remember some
important context the crew member was
talking to Kevin Smith there's no doubt
that watching the scene would have
melted his mind there are people in the
world that know what the last shot is
even if the movie's not fully cut
together at this point I'm not one of
them but as for the rest of us well
let's just hope that the final scene
will leave our brains at least lightly
singed that's not too much to hope for
is it prepare for a head spinning
experience when star wars the rise of
Skywalker arrives in theaters on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]